SARAH PALIN IS PART OF TWO COMPELLING STORY LINES.
AS ALASKA VOTES TODAY. ONE IS HER PERSONAL COMEBACK
HOPE.
SHE'S RUNNINFOR CONGRESS.
14 YEARS AFTER SPLASHING ONTO
THE NATIONAL STAGE AS JOHN
McCAIN'S RUNNING MATE.
THE FORMER ALASKA GOVERNOR HAS
HAD STINTS AS A FOX CONTRIBUTOR
AND NOW IS THE TRUMP-BACKED
CANDIDATE FOR ALASKA'S HOUSE
SEAT.
SHE'S ON TODAY'S BALLOT TWICE.
FIRST, VOTERS PICK A CANDIDATE
TO FINISH DON YOUNG'S TERM.
AND THEN VOTERS PICK CANDIDATES
FOR THE NOVEMBER BALLOT AND A
FULL TWO-YEAR TERM.
THEY WILL RANK CANDIDATES WHEN
VOTING.
OUR REPORTERS ARE BACK WITH US.
AND THIS MAKES IT A FASCINATING
EXPERIMENT.
OTHER STATES HAVE TRIED THIS
MORE AND MORE.
LET'S SHOW YOU HOW IT WORKS.
YOU RANK YOUR CANDIDATES.
NUMBER ONE, YOU PICK YOUR FIRST
CHOICE.
IF SOMEBODY GETS 50-PLUS THEY'RE
THE WINNER.
IF NOBODY CROSSES THE 50%
THRESHOLD, THE LOWEST CANDIDATE
LEAVES AND YOU GO AND COUNT
THEIR -- COUNT THEIR BALLOTS --
WHO IS THEIR SECOND CHOICE FOR
THE LOWEST CANDIDATE.
YOU GO THROUGH THIS UNTIL
SOMEBODY GETS TO 50%.
THE GOAL IS TO FORCE REPUBLICANS
TO TALK TO DEMOCRATS AND TO
FORCE DEMOCRATS TO TALK TO
REPUBLICANS BECAUSE YOU MIGHT
NEED TO BE SOMEBODY'S SECOND
CHOICE.
>> IT CAN BE A CONFUSING PROCESS
UNTIL WE ALL GET USED TO IT AS
MORE STATES ADOPT THIS PRACTICE.
BUT IT IS A GOOD IDEA IN THEORY.
IT IS GOOD THAT YOU DON'T ONLY
HAVE TO APPEAL TO THE BASE OF
YOUR PARTY AND THAT YOU HAVE TO
SPEAK TO A WIDER NUMBER OF THE
ELEC
ELECTORATE.
>> THIS COULD BE A LITTLE
CONFUSING ESPECIALLY IF YOU'RE
NOT IN ALASKA.
TODAY, YOU'RE VOTING TWICE FOR
THE HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES.
THERE ARE THREE CANDIDATES ON
THE BALLOT TODAY, PELTOLA,
BEGICH AND PALIN.
IN NOVEMBER, WE CAN SHOW YOU
THOSE SAME THREE CANDIDATES,
PLUS YOU'LL SEE TARA SWEENEY,
PLUS 18 OR 19 OTHERS OR 20-PLUS
CANDIDATES.
THESE ARE CONSIDERED THE FOUR
LEADING CANDIDATES HERE.
LET'S FOCUS ON TODAY AND LISTEN
TO THE THREE CANDIDATES, ONE OF
WHOM WILL BE IN CONGRESS AS
EARLY AS NEXT WEEK.
>> HAD SOME SHACKLES ON ME, NOT
ALLOWED TO GO ROGUE.
THAT'S WHAT OUR COUNTRY NEEDS
RIGHT NOW.
>> I'M NICK BEGICH.
I'M NOT A POLITICIAN.
BUT I'M THE ONLY CANDIDATE
ENDORSED BY THE ALASKA
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
I'LL FIGHT FOR ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE AND I'LL NEVER
QUIT.
>> THE FISH COMMISSION, WORKING
TO PROTECT ALASKA'S SALMON AND
THE ONLY CANDIDATE FIGHTING FOR
ABORTION RIGHTS.
>> I'M MARY PELTOLA AND I
APPROVE THIS MESSAGE.
>> THE LAST CANDIDATE,
INTERESTING, EVERYWHERE
DEMOCRATS ARE LOOKING FOR CLUES
AS TO WHETHER THE ABORTION
DEBATE HELPS THEM WITH VOTERS.
THAT WILL BE, AGAIN, ONE OF THE
TESTS.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
IT WILL BE TELLING TO SEE WHAT
THE RESULTS ARE WHICH WE WON'T
HAVE TONIGHT.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT COULD TAKE A
FEW WEEKS BEFORE WE --
>> THANK YOU FOR REMINDING
PEOPLE OF THAT.
>> IT'S -- SEEING IT AND
THINKING, OKAY, IT'S PRIMARY
NIGHT.
BUT WE STILL HAVE A WAYS AWAY
BEFORE WE HAVE THE RESULTS.
IT WILL BE INTERESTING TOO, WITH
THE RANK CHOICE, WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE CAN IONSERVATIVES SPLITTINE
VOTE AND THAT GIVES THEM AN
OPPORTUNITY AS WELL TO RACK UP
THE VOTES IN A DIFFERENT WAY.
WE'RE SEEING TWO WITH THIS RANK
CHOICE, PALIN HAS TALKING ABOUT
IT AS THE SCREWIEST SYSTEM.
WE'RE SEEING HOW ARE CANDIDATES
GOING TO TRY TO MANIPULATE THIS
IN THE FUTURE AND TALK ABOUT IT.
>> IT IS INTERESTING TO WATCH.
SHE WAS VERY COMPELLING AS JOHN
McCAIN'S VICE PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE.
A LOT OF REPUBLICAN WILL ARGUE
MAYBE SHE WASN'T PREPARED.
OFTENTIMES, WHEN YOU LEAVE
POLITICS, YOU DON'T COME BACK.
IT WILL BE INTERESTING TO SEE IN
THE TRUMP ENDORSEMENT HELPS.
>> AND ALSO IF SHE'S GOING TO
ENJOY BEING A MEMBER OF
CONGRESS.
SHE DOES HAVE TRUMP'S
ENDORSEMENT.
BEGICH IS A POPULAR -- OR A
COMMON -- I SAY, WELL-KNOWN NAME
IN ALASKA AS WELL.
HIS UNCLE AND FATHER ARE
POLITICIANS IN ALASKA SO HE'S
WELL-KNOWN TOO AND THERE'S NOT A
LOT OF POLLING IN ALASKA.
WE'LL SEE WHERE IT LANDS.
>> HER RE-ENTRY SEEMS
OPPORTUNISTIC ON ITS SURFACE.
THAT'S THE HIGH BAR.
SHE HAS TO APPEAL TO THESE
VOTERS AND SAY, HEY, I REALLY
WANT THIS JOB.
I WAS LOOKING ON HER CAMPAIGN
WEBSITE AND HER NUMBER ONE ISSUE
IS OIL AND GAS DRILLING.
I DON'T THINK ABOUT SARAH PALIN
AS A LEGISLATOR.
I DON'T THINK ABOUT THE ISSUES
WHEN I THINK OF HER.
AND I THINK THIS IS A
RE-BRANDING EXERCISE THAT SHE'S
TRYING TO ENGAGE IN.
I THINK OF THE MASKED SINGER,